unter beweis stellen und meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich möchte
keinen historischen abriss zum 26
oktober tun und machen aber faktum ist
dass an diesem tag auch ein klarer
auftrag an das österreichische
bundesheer tanken ist nämlich die
neutralität die souveränität österreichs
zu verteidigen zu sichern und deshalb
wir auch zeigen wohl als
österreichisches bundesheer dass wir in
der lage sind auch diese neutralität
souveränität sicherzustellen
auch auf moderne bedrohungen
entsprechende antworten haben aber
natürlich auch mit einem sehr breiten
spektrum an leistungsfähigkeit vom
katastrophenschutz über die miliz bis
hin eben auch zur klassischen
landesverteidigung hier unsere 26 hier
in graz entsprechend auch darstellen
möchten wir werden an diesem tag konnte
sie es glaube ich auch ein schönes
zeichen in den öffentlichen verkehr
kostenfrei zur verfügung stellen also
alle damen und herren die hierher kommen
und den leistungs show anschauen werden
dürfen und können mit den grazer öffis
gratis fahren
unter dem motto wir schützen österreich
zu wasser zu lande und in der luft wird
das österreichische bundesheer eine
umfassende leistungsschau in der
innenstadt von graz abhalten